ladies and gentlemen your host for the
67th annual Academy Awards David Lemmons
very much thank you
I'm out here out here I'm here I'm here
hey thank you very much now we're five
minutes late by the way if mr. Hiller is
still in the auditorium there's some
guys out on the parking lot I'd like to
talk to him about hoop dreams so
good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the 67th annual Academy
Awards I won't lie to you I'm very very
excited and I've been dying to do
something all day and I think maybe we
can take care of this
Oprah umma
uma Oprah
I feel much better
have you kids met Keanu
ladies and gentlemen before we go any
farther the people that I worked for are
back in New York City have asked me to
make the following announcement CBS has
signed off for the evening as you know
of course tonight is the night that
celebrates the phrase it's an honor just
to be nominated that's right and Jim
Carrey is subtle but you know here's the
good news losers tonight will not go
home empty-handed in fact all nominees
in the Best Actress category will get
the opportunity to have a child with
Anthony Quinn so there you go
you can't so I was thinking about this
earlier this year Newt Gingrich was
talking about how a lot of social
problems in this country could be
watched by watch and could be fixed by
watching movies and he suggested he
recommended that for example for some of
these problems we could watch Boys Town
take care of some of those problems by
watching the movie Boys Town and then he
said that you know maybe we could settle
the baseball strike and here amended
than watching Field of Dreams and I'm
thinking to myself you know instead of
being Speaker of the House maybe this
guy I'd be better off working at a
blockbuster you know
Oprah Puma Puma Oprah it's going to be
one of those things I won't be able to
stop doing all night long well ladies
gentlemen there's no getting around it
tonight is certainly an important event
almost as important as a DreamWorks
press conference are you like me are you
getting a little tired about reading
about these guys
of course Steven Spielberg Jeffrey
Katzenberg and David Geffen one of the
big stories of the year got together and
formed DreamWorks SKG their own studio
well they're a hit already aren't they
adil send a stock sky-high
and DreamWorks SKG not to be confused
with the DreamWorks etc etc' that's a
place in the valley where you buy water
beds but that's a whole different deal
but you know to me it's amazing when you
think about it what these three kids can
do with a dream with a dream and 1.8
billion dollars I actually I think that
this partnership is going to be really
really good for Hollywood because now
instead of hoping that they're not
successful individually you know it it's
really a time saver because now you can
hope they're not successful as a group
and it's a much better deal that way uma
Oprah
well of course Forrest Gump said life is
like a box of chocolates you never know
what you're gonna get it unless of
course you're sitting next to Roger
Ebert and then you know you're not gonna
get any
sorry you know I don't feel good about
that by the way ah another blockbuster
year for Hollywood
the motion picture interview with a
vampire did over a hundred million
dollars business over a hundred million
dollars visit of course now in New York
City for marketing purposes that movie
was released under the title bite me hey
you know I know that's not much of a
joke but I just thought it might be fun
in front of a billion people to say bite
me earlier this year there was a deal
now with Savoy Pictures and Sylvester
Stallone as I understand this now they
gave him 20 million dollars to star in a
yet to be determined film 20 million
dollars for a yet to be determined film
oh here right the only thing yet to be
determined is which Roman numeral goes
after the word rocky that's the only
thing right that's it
and then maybe get Oprah and uma to work
in the film one of the pictures
nominated night for a Best Foreign Film
as you know eat drink man woman who
incidentally as I understand it this is
also how Arnold Schwarzenegger asked
Maria Shriver out on their first date
oh man
oh geez
it was quite a year for romance in the
motion pictures Hugh Grant of course
kissed Andie MacDowell Warren Beatty
kissed Annette Bening and Marlon Brando
kissed Larry King whoo I think I speak
for all Americans who happen to see that
on CNN when I say ladies gentlemen when
I was given the honor of hosting the
67th annual Academy Awards I knew I had
to find out as much as I possibly could
about the motion picture industry well
living in New York City well thank you
very much I'm also doing very well and
Hooked on Phonics living in New York
City I've learned that when you really
want to know about something anything
there's a group of experts that are
always willing and eager to share their
knowledge and opinions yes New York City
cabdrivers so one night I went out
hailed some cabs and talked to cab
drivers about the Academy Awards movies
and life
you've won an Academy Award and we want
your immediate reaction and the winner
is
Charles Wow
yeah have your friends told you that you
look like a movie star
yeah oh really yeah what did they tell
you you look like a younger age every
newest thing
Oh Jerry Lewis that's great Dennis could
even see that Robert De Niro movie taxi
driver you're talking to me you're
talking to me are you talking to me are
you talking to me you talking to me are
you talking to me
what does hakuna matata mean nothing to
me I don't know either good it's fun to
say let's say it together a few times
Hakuna Matata Hakuna Matata Hakuna
Matata Hakuna Matata Matata
mm-hmm I could never Tata Akuma Turner
the circle of life are you talking to me
the circle of LA you're talking to me
you're talking to me
Hakuna Matata you talking to me Hakuna
Matata you do me a favor trying to tear
through special 3d glasses
I'll put right on
Edwyn are you enjoying the 3d glasses
yes that's fun yeah I don't
what do you like better goobers or
Raisinets Raisinets Raisinets Raisinets
Raisinets goobers when you go to the
movies you usually get some of that
movie theater popcorn yes
yeah me too I love the movie theater
popcorn would you like something now I
sure would
the impressions of movie stars or
anybody fainting on Jim James Cagney Oh
James Cagney yes
oh let's see that new Geordie rat you
dirty dirty dirty dirty rat oh that's
pretty good yeah I only do one
impression really Eddie it's a Jack
Nicholson you want to see it oh yeah go
ahead okay
gentlemen how about a nice welcome for
our New York City cab driver friend
thank you gentlemen
ah Quincy Sigourney
you